assalamu alaikum greetings of peace how
are you guys doing
guess what i got some edua dates have
you ever heard of edgewood dates
and i got the man next to me on the left
thank you for the edgewood dates and i'm
like oh how you doing mr
brown hi how you been
thanks yeah my pleasure some people
don't know yeah so how you been don't
forget the zamzam water man
the zemsen water yes and the miss walks
yeah there you go you know what our
friends for
thank you so much how you been medina
how things are medina uh things are good
i haven't figured out a way to get
younger but uh otherwise doing okay
uh do you get a chance now you know the
climate here it's uh
uh is it reaching you trump and all the
politics has it reached that end of the
world
sure and we're just kind of waiting to
see how that works out
yeah so these are the kind of things
that we're dealing with
you had not too long ago you had in
medina
the holiest city in the world i think it
was during the holiest month
you were there you know what i'm talking
about medina or mecca mecca
no it was a medina no i was in medina
the explosion that happened
oh are you talking about during ramadan
yeah during ramadan
yeah my understanding is i was fairly
close to it when it happened
yeah can you tell us because uh that's
something we're dealing with here people
always
linking back daesh this extreme radical
group and
people who really don't know anything
about islam but this is just
you know the show like on the holiest
month of the year during ramadan
during the blessed month you know that
in
medina this was it a tribute this group
had actually
what tell us what was a little bit
because you were there you lived there
tell us
fill us in on what what happened i mean
actually uh
i was down at the masjid anaboli when it
happened
but quite frankly aside from that
i really don't know the details except
for what is in the news
the other thing is now i hate to kind of
cop out on you here
but the bottom line is that i
just am completely political i don't
discuss you know these issues i don't
make fatwa
and um and i just i just stick to
my domain of interest and some people
say expertise
which is comparative religion and uh
you know the anti-atheist tawa when we
get to there tell us for the people who
are tuning in
a lot of times they get turned up
because they keep associating so i'll
just hit you with this
violence with islam and they can't get
past that so before we can
even get to a lot of these commonalities
and clearing these other misconceptions
comparative religion
some people keep thinking no i don't
want to and turn off these muslims
they're all terrorists you know
isis they what do you say about that
sure
i mean well first of all i mean you will
always have extremists i mean extremists
exist in all religions number one number
two
uh study on the acts of terrorism the
number of acts of terrorism and the
number of people who were killed from
acts of terrorism in the united states
over the past i forget whatever number
of years it was but
uh islam was not the top of the list i
mean the top of the list were actually
if i remember correctly it was uh
now i might be a little hazy on the
details but i think it was right-wing
extremists you know basically
actually fundamentalist christians and
uh and
uh you know this is the thing that's
just kind of annoying to us as muslims
is that
any muslim does anything and
he's his religion is mentioned you know
i mean he commits a
an any kind of a crime and it's like you
know
this muslim did that but you know any
christian does anything yeah
serial killing a schoolyard shooting
uh you know anything like that and they
put in totally different terms they say
oh he went postal
or you know the guy was psychologically
disturbed or whatever and they never
mentioned the religion
you know i mean was the last time you
ever heard you know christian extremist
christian terrorist or something like
this never and uh
so there's there does appear to be this
this
strong bias in the media
to i mean i feel really to demonize
islam
and to make christianity just sort of
sweep
sweep christianity and judaism's
problems
under the carpet you know you never
again buddhists you never hear of
buddhist terrorists but look at what's
going on buddhist terrorism
but look at what's going on in in
myanmar and look look what's going on
with the
uh you know the genocide
the genocide that that buddhists are are
committing
in in the far east you know and yet you
never hear this
as you know buddhist terrorism so you
know there's
there's a attempt on the media to
polarize things which i'm
definitely not comfortable with and it
does seem grossly prejudicial
yeah we've done we've answered these
questions on many previous episodes we
won't spend too much time on it
go ahead what were you going to say well
by the way i do want to say something
and it is one of my
sort of pet peeves is that um you know i
think
all of this i mean if not all but you
know
90 some percent 95 98 really comes from
9 11. i mean i was muslim before 9 11
and i'm muslim now and
you know alhamdulillah by the grace of
allah but i saw the transition between
how americans thought and treated
muslims
before 9 11 and after and
i really feel that was kind of the
defining moment before 9 11
there was still some media bias i mean
but there was quite a lot of media bias
but then
when 9 11 happened it just
ramped things up tremendously okay
and this is one a pet peeve i have
because
number one okay if it was muslims
who carried out the atrocity of 9 11
it was a crime the muslim world
recognizes it as a crime and the muslim
world
is trying to send this message to the
west to the developed countries
basically saying look this was a crime
those are criminals they don't represent
our understanding of islam they don't
understand our
they don't represent you know our values
they don't represent represent our
morality or our religious values
okay so don't try to to to say that this
is you know is islam this was the act of
a criminal
no different from the act of a criminal
of any other denomination or religion in
the world
okay that's number one but number two is
uh
you know there's been this growing
movement that
questions brand new poll that show that
more and more americans
are rethinking what happened on 9 11 and
increasingly more people are saying they
do not believe the government's version
of events
you know questions where or how
9 11 actually happened 911 and candidly
wouldn't only fringe people still
question what happened on 9 11
well perhaps not today we're going to
release to you results of a brand new
poll that show that more and more
americans
are rethinking what happened on 9 11.
and i mean for example
so there are all kinds of reasons we
thought we were set up to fail
we got started late we had a very short
time frame
indeed we had to get it extended we did
not have enough money
they were they were afraid we were going
to hang somebody
that we would point the finger lee and i
write in our book that
we think the commission in many ways was
set up to fail
because we had not enough money
we didn't have enough time we've been
appointed by the most partisan people in
washington
um there's an excellent
excellent expose on um
on youtube or at least it used to be on
youtube called
9 11 mysteries demolitions
it's an hour and a half video you can
watch or you can purchase
i think the last time i looked for it
you actually had to go to amazon.com to
buy it
i mean the just the best money you'll
ever spend in researching this topic
okay if you can watch that video
and not have your convictions changed
regarding how
9 11 happened then
you just kind of you need to get an eeg
you know an eeg an electrocephalogram
something to check your brain waves
i mean if you can watch that that
documentary
and walk away with the conviction
that that you came in with something's
just wrong
and and and so i just have to say that
you know
this is just the plug i've got i've got
to give is stop
demonizing not just islam
but stop demonizing any group
we are living in a time and we are
living in a culture
that loves to hate or needs to hate okay
i mean as long as i have been alive
and for a lot of time before
the west or the developed countries has
always been demonizing a group
i mean if it wasn't like the only good
indian as a dead indian
you know you you come forward into world
war ii
where you know the germans were krauts
and then
you know the korean war with where the
koreans were the gooks and then
into the vietnamese war where the you
know they weren't vietnamese no no they
were charlie or slants or something like
this you know
and you know every different person is
given a name that is
is dehumanizing them okay you're not you
know you're not
killing you know you're not killing a
person you're killing a crowd
world war ii you know you know you're
not killing a a north korean you're
killing a [ __ ]
you know it's you know an ugly word you
know you're not you're not killing at
vietnamese you're killing a slant
i mean where does this ugliness come
from but this is
it's a process of basically
programming a people to see another
people
as as something different from what they
are
and every single time every single time
after the massacre you know
after the dust settles we turn around
and we start realizing that we're
rubbing shoulders with these people and
they're okay
you know the indians that we massacred
the american indians
that we massacred we now go and visit
their rev
their reservations we enjoy their art we
enjoy their
food we see the beauty of their customs
and the gentleness of their natures
after world war ii the you know there
are all these touching stories
of soldiers who were united with their
counterparts
you know and the the american you know
the american
uh soldier who was uh interned in a
prison of war camp
and uh suffered horribly during his
internment and
and uh later after the war is united
with his captors
and they both just realized we were we
were on different sides of the equation
and we're both okay
you know or the one who was shot down by
another pilot or
or uh you know was
you know intimately involved in the
struggle of life and death and the
struggle of the war against
another counterpart with which they were
united later and
you know later and they just realized
you know i mean
we're all human you know i mean the
germans
in this country the japanese in this
country where'd they come from the same
countries that we were fighting
and what do we think about them now i
mean
i mean sushi you know i mean everybody
knows
knows a japanese person if nothing else
just from our
our food culture and and you know we we
found that
the people that we were killing before
we found that the people that we were
fighting before on the basis of
ideology who we thought were less than
human they're okay
yeah after the vietnam war i mean you
couldn't go into a convenience store in
america except you had a high chance
that you're going to be
doing business with the vietnamese and
and they were okay and was a shock of
shocks
you know i mean they're just like us
they they just want to live life and
and you know have a peaceful existence
and so on and so forth that's the the
power of the human connection
i'm just saying look i'm just saying
with whether you're talking about
the you know the forces that we're at
war with in world war ii
where you're talking about you know
mussolini's italy
and uh you know in that period or
whether you're talking about the
the you know the nazi germans or whether
you're talking about the japanese
i'm talking about you know koreans
during the korean war the vietnamese uh
it it just doesn't matter what pool you
look at
i mean once you started once these
people
were conquered and we found ourselves
you know they
emigrated and we found ourselves living
next to them
we found all of our preconceptions
dispelled we found that we had been
lied to we found that we had been
deceived
and we found that it was all for the
purpose
of an agenda that was beyond us
okay so when are we going to wake up
when are when are we going to open our
minds and recognize
that we are being misled for a purpose
for an agenda good points
more to come with dr lawrence brown here
in the dean's show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the d show with my special
friend good friend dr lawrence brown
before i get to my next question you
brought up 911
and obviously that was a catalyst to
where we are today
have you heard of it's interesting these
aren't just lay people
but somewhat around 3.000
engineers scientists
politicians former presidential
candidates it took some kind of
consciousness raising on my part before
i was willing to
look at the possibilities and really you
need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
i have three degrees in engineering
i signed that petition for architects
and engineers
for 9 11 truth some time ago because the
american people
absolutely need the truth of 9 11.
look at the evidence in fact i'll say
this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought
forward has got to come away with the
feeling
that something has to be done a real
investigation
has to be put forward we're all
demanding who signed a petition
to reopen the investigation have you
heard of these
architects and engineers for 9 11 truth
oh sure
and you know one of the things that i
find very very uh
striking about this is that is not only
the collection
of experts in their fields who are
looking at the evidence looking at the
body of the evidence and saying
you know the official story no that just
doesn't do it
i mean that's you know we we've got to
re-examine this and
and come to a more sensible conclusion i
mean look
911 did not you know the the official
story
it did not even answer how building
number seven came down
okay uh the greatest mystery of 911
how does a complete building come down
it wasn't wasn't touched by the air it
wasn't hit by the airplanes
okay had a couple of minor little fires
of it inside it from debris that you
know
uh was scattered into it and you just
look at it and just one moment it drops
to the ground
in the perfect picture of controlled
demolitions
okay now i'm i'm just saying that
i'm not the only one who's looked at
that and just said
man something's wrong but you're just
saying something's wrong you're you're
you're observing
you're you're questioning but now why is
it why is it when you question
you're not making up some some
conspiracy but they call you conspiracy
theorists as soon as you question
like when you hear the fire man they
said
all my floors
you're just asking questions you're not
coming up with a theory what happened
you're just asking questions why did
they put you in this box
conspiracy theorist the definition of a
conspiracy is when two or more people
acting in concert knowingly commit
an offense or or or a crime all right
a a misdemeanor a felony an offense
that is the definition of a conspiracy
was this a conspiracy
absolutely yes it was and those people
need to go
to jail for treason you can't even ask a
question
yeah but you're just supposed to accept
what's been told to you accept this
right official story
mainstream done right don't ask anymore
as i said i had 32 years there and i was
also a trained
fire marshal a fire marshal is
considered an expert witness in court
he's like a a forensic detective
he has the power to administer the oath
take testimony and issue a subpoena
that's a lot of power
it was there was an explosion the
building
did come down in complete classical
controlled demolition it came down on
its own footprint
there's no question about that as a
matter of fact richard gage from
architects and engineers has
completely handled that from his area of
expertise
never in the history of a world never in
the history of
high-rise skyscrapers has ever
a skyscraper ever come down
because of fire and i'm talking massive
fire and you know the reason why
because fire does not burn by itself
hot enough to compromise and melt
steel what we had
in the world trade center and i saw
myself
was molten lava like pockets of molten
steel
all right i spent the night on the pile
searching
for bodies and i saw that with my own
eyes
so who are you going to believe are you
going to believe a bunch of
government bureaucrats or my fellow
brothers
which i lost 343 guys that day
right and and and you you start talking
like this and they say oh that's
conspiratorial thinking as if there's no
such thing as conspiracy as if
conspiracy don't happen
conspiracies don't happen you know as as
if
america does not have excites did not
commit black flag
operations did not have uh
what is it called extraordinary
rendition you know did not have the cia
with the box of dirty tricks overseas
and so on and so forth
you know i i mean just it's just it's
just a way of making you look bad or
silent silencing you for having an open
mind
but one of the things that is most
convincing to me
is that is the body of
you know the group of people who lost
love
loved ones in 9 11 who are demanding a
reinvestigation because
they don't exist the family member the
official yeah the family members
i'm a family member trying to find out
the answers to the murder of 3 000
plus people
bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated
properly
please look at architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this
and there's some deep deep explaining to
do
we will never heal this country will
never ever
ever forget that day we have to demand
a new investigation i want justice here
because they don't accept the official
explanation
and that many of them are the ones who
are you know they are the ones who are
saying
that it was an inside job now
i'm not i'm not going to say what my
viewpoint
on this is i'm just going to say that my
message to people is don't close your
mind
open your mind and in the same way that
we are asking
for a re-examination of the evidence
people out there should re-examine the
evidence themselves
so they should be listening to i mean
you've
you've got eminent experts in their
fields
who are demanding a re-examination of
the evidence you have
as an engineer i have three degrees in
engineering
i signed that petition for architects
and engineers for 9 11 truth some time
ago
because the american people absolutely
need the truth
of 9 11. you know really really great
documentaries like this one i mentioned
9 11
mysteries demolitions it's 911 mysteries
like slash demolitions
okay um and uh uh
what's it gonna take to watch it you
know one of the things that i find
really disturbing about this though
is that 911 is like it's people have
views on it that approach the level of
religious zeal
you know when you talk about when you
talk about a religion
or when you talk about religious views a
lot of people there
it's just clear that their minds are
closed and you just can't talk to them
because if you say anything that is
contrary
to to their way of looking at things
they
they don't want to hear it it's like no
no no it can't be it can't be no no no
no
you know and then they express their
view they keep repeating their view you
know
you know it's this way it's this way
it's this way and
you know um you know yeah the evidence
points over here
and or you know or you know you point
out the contradictions to them or you
point out how they're basically
you know not following the path of logic
or you know they're not many times
they're not even following the teachings
of their own book
you know and when it comes to 911 it's
the same way they just say no no
no you know it's like the you know the
three monkeys with their hands over
their eyes ears and
and uh what is it now eyes ears and
mouth yeah
you know except except they i wish they
would put their hand over their mouth
but they don't that's the one that's the
one hand they keep away they keep
talking
but with their eyes closing their ears
closed just kind of no no no muslims are
bad no this was islamic terrorism no no
you know you know and and they're not
willing to examine the evidence
and consider the possibility
that this is all the part of a greater
agenda
and but but at the
very least just consider the possibility
that like i said muslims and islam
is not you know it's not as bad as how
it's being portrayed why is our news
media foaming at the mouth when it comes
to stories about islamic terrorists
but not white guy terrorists it's not
because muslims are a bigger threat
in fact between nineteen eighty and two
thousand five
ninety four percent of all the attempted
or successful terrorist attacks
on u s soil were not carried out by
islamic radicals
but instead by non-muslims mostly white
guys
so then why the obsession islam
is killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious in this country
do they blow people up yes christians
every day people walk in the post
i mean people walk into post offices
they walk into schools that's what
columbine i mean i can do this all day
long there's so
there are so many more examples of
christians and i happen to be a
christian
that's back to this notion of your
idealizing christianity in my mind to my
read
there's so many more examples of john of
christians who do that then you could
ever give me examples of muslims who
have done that
inside this country where you live and
work but we we can say
clearly we can close the door that islam
has
nothing doesn't justify acts like this
even at the end of the day if some crazy
deranged individual or group of
individuals
went and killed innocent people which by
the way
muslims and hundreds have died in this
this has nothing to do with islam
islam condemns this there is no
justification for it
this is clear this is something that
there's no shadow of a doubt
about that now we're talking about even
questioning it further but it seems like
this is
something that is a tool that's used to
demonize the whole
way of life of islam well
as i said i mean you've heard my
viewpoint first of all i just
i want to correct myself on something i
said you know something about how
you know people should conclude that
islam is not as bad as it's being
portrayed
i mean actually for myself as muslim i
have to just say that you know i would
hope people would conclude
that islam is not bad period you know i
mean the more
the more you examine islam you know and
anybody i've known who's examined islam
with an open mind
it just starts to understand
start to realize that everything's
upside down everything is the opposite
of
how how they were trained to believe you
know that it's actually a
it's it's a beautiful religion it is
consistent with the continuity in the
chain of revelation from the previous
prophets it clarifies previous
revelation
and it brings us to a conclusion of the
chain of revelation
from the abra from abraham to ishmael
and isaac to moses
jesus to muhammad you know there is
there's a
chain of revelation there and if you you
know if you are
on a spiritual spiritual search and
looking for the completion of revelation
you have to look
for what you have to look for the three
prophets that the old testament
predicted john the baptist and jesus
christ are one and two and then you have
to look for the final prophet the third
and final prophet that was predicted
not only in the old testament but also
in the words of jesus predicting a third
prophet
who would come and another paraclete
you know who would basically clarify
okay and and that third prophet is the
prophet muhammad
so now i'm just i'm just saying okay i'm
just saying
that you know islam is a religion that
more people
you know who open in their hearts and
open their minds and look at it
from an open perspective just feel
that they've been lied to you know they
they say you know i
was these i always thought these people
were bad i always thought this was
religion was bad but but you know i i
mean actually there's so much beauty
here and this is
and this conforms with what i already
believed and this conforms with
you know the the revelation that you
know i studied before
and uh and and this clarifies it and and
now i understand
so i'm you know look i'm just you know
we
we live in a funny time people people
need
to get their information in postcard
format you know
if you can't fit it into what is it 140
some characters and a twit
you know i mean if you can't if you
can't twit it
uh if if you can't if you can't uh
encapsulate it in a very very brief
message that conforms to people's
sort of shortened attention span in this
time yeah it's very hard for people to
to engage in in an intellectual debate
what about you there was a gentleman and
there's a lot of cases like this
where they get fed a lot of this false
information
false fears that oh you're going over to
jeddah or you're going over to that side
of the world
you actually live in that so you're a
former major in the uh
u.s navy is that right air force air
force i'm sorry
um and you you've been living over you
accepted this way of light used to be an
atheist trying hard to be a
christian we have your story from the
past but many people who've been fed
these lies
they actually go over there and they
experience the love and hospitality
you must have experienced it because
you've been living there for how long
now tell us about this
your experience is there 17 years and by
the way my my daughter off camera is
showing me little signs saying
it's not a twit you twit it's a tweet so
but that shows that shows you how much
attention i give to social media i feel
social media is
not is not the pathway to intelligent
discourse it's
you know social media gives you a
postcard version
at best for people with extremely
shortened attention spans i mean if
i mean come on if you're going to engage
in the debate if you are going to
hang your afterlife on this you really
cannot take the time to read a book you
really cannot take the time to
you know to investigate in a serious way
i mean this is your afterlife you've got
you've got 70 years to figure it out but
you
or 60 years or 80 years or for some
people you know they die even younger
but
but it this is going to be your eternity
and you cannot devote a little time for
it you you can't give up
on a movie one night or a tv show the
next or whatever to
to actually cram for the final exam
i mean come on really i mean if that's
what you die upon
you almost kind of deserve it because
you've been
ignoring the one who created you and put
you on this
earth for the purpose of knowing him and
serving and worshiping him
you know and you've just totally ignored
it you've just blown it off it's like
playing xbox your whole life yeah i mean
you know it's just
it's ungrateful it's ungrateful and it's
irresponsible
yeah now your experience how you've been
living there
have you this gentleman one in
particular i forgot his name they had
him on i think huda tv
and american christian and he was told
like these guys are gonna if you go over
there you might
you know have your head cut off oh yeah
and then he he goes there and again he
said man
they were so hospitable loving and he
actually
he was a god-fearing christian he said
you know god
he basically in in summary was asking
just guide me god whatever
you know to the truth he ended up
accepting islam we'll show a little clip
here my friends at the u.s naval academy
in annapolis maryland
they said do you know what you're doing
you're putting yourself
in harm's way you're going to get
kidnapped somebody's going to cut your
throat so when i arrived in saudi arabia
i was scared to death
i didn't know quite what to expect but i
when i left the united states i said god
my mind is open i don't know what is
islam
i've never been in an islamic country
before and
i don't know about the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
but show me what is truth and what is
not truth
and i came with an open mind and looking
looking nothing happened people were
coming out of their houses
when they saw me inviting me into their
homes for tea and coffee
subhanallah the exact opposite
incredible this was not
what i expected wow i had been in
countries all over the world i studied
in taiwan in russia and different places
but never in my life have i been in any
country
that respected me as much as an american
and even as a christian
as saudi arabia grace and mercy
forgiveness of sins
wow my life was transformed
immediately it was the love of god in
the love of the muslims around me
that drew me to islam now you're there
you're living there i mean is this
tell us a little bit about this when
people do go down there
when they get out of their neighborhood
and then they get out to other parts of
the world yeah
how fictitious this is i mean just
completely i've been living in the
middle east for 17 years when i went
over there
uh people gave me these warnings about
you know you know watch yourself it's
dangerous the people are like this this
might happen that might happen now i've
lived there
before 9 11 i was in medina when 9 11
happened
and i've lived there ever since okay
and i have never had anything except for
for
you know basically the best treatment
well i shouldn't say never there's
always you know a few isolated
incidences of
you know the same as you'd have here on
the street in america where
you know you just you know don't hit it
off with somebody but
but i mean i've just i've just had the
best of a treatment i mean i remember
after 9 11
after 9 11 i just remember all of these
saudis coming up to me and apologizing
and just you know very sincerely saying
we're so
sorry for what happened to your country
and it's not their fault these are these
these are
are beautiful polite well-mannered
people
you know once you're in their presence
you
feel their gentleness they weren't
dancing in the streets i heard the
common mantras that
when this happened people were dancing
and celebrating no that's ridiculous
i mean i i never saw that and i was have
you heard this cliche have you heard
this
no actually i haven't but but you know i
mean i i did not see
any of that and i didn't i haven't
talked with anybody who did
and i was living there okay and i'm in
medina one of the holy cities if you
if you expect to see that anywhere if
that were the manner of the people you
would expect to have seen that there but
i
i did not have people to you know do
anything
but apologize to me and say you know
we're really sad that this happened
and and you know telling me as a muslim
telling me you know that this is not
part of our religion i said yeah i know
that and they said you know
you know we're no you know we're against
this i said yes of course uh of course i
know we're against this and
and so on but uh you know aside i mean
aside from that
just in general i have to say the
propaganda that i have been aware of
is always from what i've seen it's just
always contrary to the truth
i mean why have i been in saudi arabia
for 17 years
i mean these these people
have extended their arm of hospitality
towards me in their country
and they have given me a beautiful life
there i i feel
safer in saudi arabia walking walking
down a a small alley which by the way i
do all the time
going to prayer you know in the morning
sometimes three in the morning sometimes
four in the morning
i feel i feel safer walking down a small
dark
unlit alley right at three or four in
the morning
then i do sometimes uh just
in open daylight here in america you
know the
the the incidence of crime is so low
the and it's just basic values
you know that the arabs have this very
high respect
for honesty for generosity
for hospitality you know and they try to
excel at these things you know they
you know it's it's uh it's one of the
teachings when you go into
an arab household in the middle east
don't
look at anything because if you allow
your
eyes to a light on something in the room
and the host notices they'll just take
that thing and give it to you
i mean it might even be something very
valuable i i remember one time
uh you know when i was fairly new in
medina uh i just
i saw this rug in this guy's house
very beautiful well handmaded han
knotted rug i mean i i would estimate
its value would be in the
you know maybe around five six thousand
dollars you know small knots and i mean
i mean just a beautiful handmade uh you
know carpet
and uh the guy just saw me looking at it
and that was it he had to give it to me
now this this doesn't go
after him being an arab this is because
of the teachings that the almighty sent
from islam correct
this is where do they get this now this
is um i think it's a combination
because like even even even before the
religion of islam
there you know there was this extreme
extremely generous
arab named uh i think it was hatam if i
remember correctly
and so they even have this you know this
saying
to be as generous as hatam because he he
set this example for
uh generosity but you know i mean go
back to
go back to abraham and that time where
you know a guest would arrive an
unknown guest and you would just
slaughter the fatted calf
there are beautiful people and i think
part of you know part of that
is uh just innate they're they're a
beautiful
generous people what if someone says
look oh you're sellout now you know like
for myself i'm i'm i'm
he's an arab now no no you can't
obviously change your your nationality
look
i i'm an american i love my country but
at the same time i'm
conscious of my purpose in life i love
my creator
i live this beautiful way of life but i
also respect other people's cultures i'm
open to learn
but if someone you know uh says
something like this oh now you're you
you sell out
you know you hear all sorts of ignorant
things first of all yeah first of all
stop listening to me okay i mean go
listen to
all the other non-muslims okay
non-muslims who
have come to the middle east and found
themselves you know
welcomed and well treated by
well-mannered generous hospitable people
my life was transformed immediately
it was the love of god in the love of
the muslims around me
that drew me to islam okay and
um you know you know be convinced by
them don't be convinced by me i've known
so many people like this that they're
just
you know uh they're non-muslims but
they don't want to leave the middle east
yeah and some of them leave the middle
east in tears
because you know their their job has you
know their contract has ended their job
has run out or something like that
i mean some of them leave the middle
east in tears because they
don't want to leave this beautiful
environment that they found now
let me just back up for a minute please
understand
okay i'm not trying to completely uh
you know come completely uh
how do you say it i mean make things
look you know completely rosy all right
because uh there are good and bad people
everywhere
okay so i'm not i'm not saying you know
these people are bad these people are
good this place is bad that place is
good no there are good and bad people
everywhere
but it's on a spectrum
okay and what i can say is
what i can say is that i
i feel so happy and
so comfortable in in the presence
of the brothers and sisters who welcome
me
into their homes and into their country
in saudi arabia
i never want to leave yeah i love these
people
what my my patients you know the the
arab patients i have
i love these people you know it is a
privilege to me it's it's not just a job
it is a privilege to me that allah has
put me in a position
where i can treat these people and be
an agent through which they regain their
eyesight
okay an agent because all good things
are from allah but okay i'm i'm an
agent through which this happens and
it's a privilege to me
that you know the powers that be in in
saudi arabia have accepted me as a guest
into their country and and honors me in
that position yeah
we've got a few more minutes i want to
touch upon a few other things i mean
that's that's the power of the human
connection
not just closing yourself off from other
cultures
other ways of life and going beyond what
you've been
brainwashed to believe and this is a
testimony of many testimony
of other people who've experienced again
that love that compassion
and this is what we should be working
towards you know growing is humanity
tell us there's a
professor here in chicago dr pape
who said since we're on this topic he
said that
this is an expert a terrorism expert he
evaluated a thousand plus terrorist acts
and he said
this is not some just random individual
an expert he says islam has little to
nothing
to do with these terrorist attacks
this is all politically motivated have
you heard of dr pape in
this uh analysis the study that he did
uh i haven't because i work in a
different field as i said my
and before and before 9 11 you didn't
have if you go back you didn't have
these groups as such as al-qaeda
daesh isis all of these things we're
trying to find out the root
where these things come from it's not
like islam is inherently bad and it's
calling you to go ahead and
strap bombs but you have extreme
elements these he's talking about these
are politically motivated
yeah i mean i haven't heard of him or
these
uh you know these conclusions but it
doesn't surprise me because
you know i think i'm just guessing but
i'm guessing that what he is trying to
say
is basically that islam is not
associated with terrorism because we
know that the islamic beliefs are not
consistent with these acts there may be
muslims
there may be muslims who have committed
acts of terrorism in the same way that
they're muslims who may have committed
crimes
and you know christians and jews and
atheists and
everybody else okay there are good and
bad people everywhere all right but
i mean we're talking about a religion of
what 1.2 1.3
billion people i'm a huge portion of
the uh population of this earth so
you can't expect you know all of them to
be uh peaceful law-abiding citizens
you'll find some criminals in that mix
yeah all right but so what he's really
saying is that you might have some
criminal muslims
but those people don't speak for the
religion stop demonizing the religion
stop marginalizing the religion for the
acts of the few
i mean if you if you look at okay let's
let's say
that there were 22 muslim terrorists
who carried out 911 and that's a big
that's a big
you know uh presumption but let's say
that there were what is 22 out of 1.3
billion why aren't you looking at the
1.3 billion
and not looking at the 22 in the same
way that you look at christian america
okay you look at well i almost hate to
say christian america anymore because
the number of christians is waning and
those you know those who are christian
are
very often you know sort of marginal
christians
uh but in any case you know you look at
christian and american
christian america and they don't accept
for their religion to be demonized
when there's found to be a christian
serial killer
or a christian who goes postal and you
know commits and
you know that happens daily or the kkk
attributing the whole religion to the
kkk
christian that sect that's obvious to to
distinguish the two i don't even know if
the kkk is still active
they're active they have two almost 200
live branches right now you can go sign
up
right now if you wanted they have
websites they're ready to
hire and fire and they're in fully
functional what do you mean by fire
kick you out if you if you if you this
if you disengage from those
extreme radical beliefs you probably get
kicked out you're gonna get fired okay
you get what i'm saying yeah so in any
case i mean you know i'm
i'm just you know i'm just saying that
uh you know you shouldn't demonize the
religion for the acts of a few and i
think this this man that you're talking
about is probably just
just saying you know differentiate
between muslims and islam
yeah okay you might find some bad
muslims you know you might find some
muslims that can
conduct acts of terrorism but if that's
not consistent with the religion of
islam
if that if that is not from the islamic
teachings then islam is not responsible
for that these guys are these bad guys
are
but the religion is not yeah give us a
tweet give us something to end with we
got it we're out of time give us
something for the person tuning in
they're watching us
and they don't know much about muslims
islam they're hearing this stuff for the
first time
they're saying you white caucasian what
are your eyes green or blue what's that
and they're like okay you know this is
interesting you gotta get out there you
gotta get out there you gotta
look one thing i wanted to say is a lot
of the muslims not a lot
almost all almost all of the muslims i
have ever met i've been
i've traveled to jordan kuwait bahrain
of course saudi arabia palestine
israel and turkey and
i'm in a number of number of countries
in the middle east okay
and everybody i have ever met is
frustrated
frustrated frustrated and they're always
saying the same thing they're saying why
did
you know why did the west see us like
this you know i mean this is this is not
who
we're you know we're okay and if people
actually went and lived with them they'd
find out that that's true they'd find
out that these people
are you know they're calm they're
peaceful they're loving
they are like i said they're hospitable
they're generous
and this has to come from somewhere and
and yeah part of it is their nature and
part of it is their
their religion fine-tuning their nature
okay
of course you know that that's just i
mean those are the moral constraints
that they live within also from the
religion but it's a beautiful thing and
you have to experience it to understand
the other thing i'd say is check out my
website leveltruth.com leveltruth.com
leveltruth.com it's got a lot of
material if you if you are on a
spiritual search as i was saying read a
book
start with mine i mean start start with
the first and final commandment
or start with misguided and don't think
i'm trying to sell anything
go to the website download it free of
charge it's all there
on on pdf download
just read thank you for the zem zim and
the edgewood dates and the miss walk
always a pleasure make sure you stop in
next time you're in town as always and
thank you guys walk with a muslim talk
with the muslim visit hamas
call us 1-800 make the human connection
and visit me here every week visit us
here at thedeanshow.com
like us on what is it facebook follow me
on twitter
stay up to date with the d show we
started with peace we don't repeat so
i'll make him peace be with you